It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的生意规模正在迅速扩大。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有顶级优先数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使在蜂巢忙碌时，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这可是一个不会一直有的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。
GoogleFi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Over the past few decades, the U.S. has become an increasingly less religious country. One recent Gallup poll found that since 1973, the percentage of Americans saying they have no religion has grown from 5% to 22%, while the percentage you identify with a Christian denomination dropped from 87% to 68%. Hidden in these numbers are many stories of people who grew up with religion, but chose at some point in their lives to leave the faith they were raised with. In recent years, psychologists have become interested in understanding both the factors driving this exodus from religion and the experiences of the people who leave it. So why is the U.S.
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负载时段不受数据流量降速限制。在过去的几十年里，美国已经变得越来越不那么宗教化了。最近的一项盖洛普民意调查发现，自 1973 年以来，声称自己没有宗教信仰的美国人比例已从 5% 增长到 22%，而认同基督教派别的比例则从 87% 下降到 68%。这些数字背后隐藏着许多人的故事，他们从小在宗教环境中长大，但在人生的某个阶段选择了离开从小接受的信仰。近年来，心理学家开始有兴趣了解导致这种宗教出走潮的因素，以及离开宗教的人们的经历。那么，为什么美国
becoming less religious? Why do people choose to leave religion and where do they go when they do? What spiritual, social, and other challenges do formerly religious people face? And how can people make new meaning in their lives after leaving religion. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Darrell von Tongarin, a professor of psychology at Hope College in Holland, Michigan. His research focuses on some of life's biggest questions, including how people make meaning in life, the psychology of morality and virtue, the role of religion, and why people leave religion. Dr. Van Tongeren's research has
变得越来越不那么宗教化了？为什么人们选择离开宗教，离开后他们又去了哪里？曾经有宗教信仰的人面临着哪些精神、社会和其他方面的挑战？人们在离开宗教后，又该如何在生活中创造新的意义？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是 Kim Mills。我今天的嘉宾是密歇根州荷兰市霍普学院的心理学教授 Darrell von Tongeren 博士。他的研究专注于人生中一些最重大的问题，包括人们如何创造人生意义、道德与美德的心理学、宗教的作用，以及人们为何离开宗教。Van Tongeren 博士的研究已经
been covered by many media outlets, including the New York Times, The Washington Post, the BBC, and the Atlantic. He's authored more than 200 scientific publications and four books, including his newest, Dun, How to Flourish After Leaving Religion, which was published by APA Books in July. Dr. Van Tongeren, thank you for joining me today. Thanks for having me, Kim. Happy to be here. Let's talk about how the religious landscape has changed in the U.S. over the past several years.
被许多媒体报道，包括《纽约时报》、《华盛顿邮报》、英国广播公司（BBC）和《大西洋月刊》。他撰写了 200 多篇科学出版物和四本书，其中包括他今年 7 月由美国心理学会出版社出版的最新著作《离开宗教后如何蓬勃发展》（Done: How to Flourish After Leaving Religion）。Van Tongeren 博士，感谢您今天接受我的采访。谢谢你的邀请，Kim。很高兴来到这里。让我们谈谈过去几年美国宗教格局发生了怎样的变化。
I just mentioned a couple of statistics in the intro. Can you expand on them how much less religious are Americans than we used to be? Yeah, so some stats suggest that whereas 90% of people used to identify as religious that's dropped into the low 60s, some predict that by 2070 Christianity will no long be the majority religion in the U.S. And in fact, one in three people raised Christian will likely leave the faith by the time they turn 30. It's an increasingly less religious landscape in the U.S.
我刚才在开场白中提到了几个统计数据。您能展开讲讲吗？美国人比过去少了多少宗教信仰？是的，一些统计数据表明，过去有 90% 的人认同自己有宗教信仰，而这一比例已降至 60% 出头。有人预测，到 2070 年，基督教将不再是美国的多数派宗教。事实上，三分之一在基督教家庭长大的人很可能会在 30 岁之前离开这种信仰。美国的宗教氛围确实越来越淡了。
And among the religious nuns, about three quarters of them are religious done. So people who are walking away from their faith. And when you say religious nuns, that's N-O-N-E, right? When I talking about N-U-Ns? That's right. That's exactly right. And now, in your book, you described four main reasons that people leave religion. and you call them the four horsemen of religion's apocalypse.
在这些宗教“无神论者”（nuns）中，约四分之三是“宗教完成者”（religious done），也就是那些正在远离信仰的人。当你提到宗教“nuns”时，是指 N-O-N-E（无宗教信仰者），对吧？而不是指 N-U-N-S（修女）？没错，正是这样。现在，在您的书中，您描述了人们离开宗教的四个主要原因，并将它们称为“宗教启示录的四骑士”。
Why don't you tell us about those? Sure. Now, these reasons why people are leaving religion is based on data and studies conducted by myself and other colleagues. So the first reason why people leave is what we call cultural stagnation. So people are becoming increasingly more progressive with their religious institutions art. So they might give intellectual reasons for leaving. They may say that they outgrew their faith. And a lot of times this shows up where one's personal values,
您能给我们讲讲这些原因吗？当然。人们离开宗教的原因是基于我和其他同事进行的数据和研究。人们离开的第一个原因是所谓的“文化停滞”。人们在变得越来越进步，而他们的宗教机构却没有。因此，他们可能会给出离开的理智理由。他们可能会说自己已经超越了信仰。很多时候，这种情况表现为个人的价值观
no longer coincide with one's religious institutions' values. So, for example, people might leave because their church is not affirming of LGBTQ-plus individuals, or their church has rather conservative or regressive views on gender or sexuality. The second reason why people might leave is because religious abuse or trauma. Some people have recounted personal experiences where religious leaders have abused them or they've experienced religious or spiritual trauma. Others know people who have experienced such horrific offenses, and still others can't quite reconcile the hypocrisy of church leaders, such as the abuse scandal among Catholic clergy, and so have decided that they should leave. A third reason why people leave is when they face
不再与宗教机构的价值观相符。例如，人们可能会因为教会不认可 LGBTQ+ 群体，或者教会对性别或性取向持有相当保守或倒退的观点而离开。人们离开的第二个原因是宗教虐待或创伤。有些人讲述了宗教领袖虐待他们的个人经历，或者他们经历过宗教或精神创伤。另一些人认识经历过此类可怕罪行的人，还有一些人无法调和教会领袖的虚伪，例如天主教神职人员中的虐待丑闻，因此决定离开。人们离开的第三个原因是，当他们面临
adversity, their religious institutions have given them an overly thin account for suffering. So they can't quite make sense of experiencing personal diversity. And so some religious organizations promote things like the prosperity gospel or toxic positivity, which we psychologists basically call the just world hypothesis. So good things happen to good people, bad things happen to bad people. If adversity happens to you, does that mean that you're a bad person? Or does it mean that God or some supernatural agent had the power to save you but decided not to or maybe even worse doesn't care about you or cause these horrible things to happen? And then the fourth reason why people might leave is because religion is a problematic label.
逆境时，他们的宗教机构对苦难的解释过于单薄。因此，他们无法理解自己经历的个人逆境。一些宗教组织宣扬诸如“成功神学”或“有毒的正能量”，我们心理学家将其称为“公正世界假设”。即好人有好报，坏人有恶报。如果你遭遇了逆境，那是否意味着你是个坏人？或者这是否意味着上帝或某种超自然力量有能力拯救你，却决定不救，甚至更糟的是，它根本不在乎你，或者导致了这些可怕事情的发生？第四个离开的原因是“宗教”这个标签本身就有问题。
So some people do not want to be associated with the term religious. And in the United States, particularly since 2016, religion and evangelical in particular, has carried a different meaning and connotation. So two years ago, a poll revealed that among self-identified evangelicals, 40% don't believe in the deity of Jesus. Now, I'm not a theologian, but I'm pretty sure that's the one you, thing the most evangelicals would agree on, which suggests that this term has a different sociopolitical meaning, and some people don't want to be identified or associated with it. What about people who kind of cherry-pick the things that they want to believe about a religion?
有些人不想与“宗教”这个词联系在一起。在美国，特别是在 2016 年之后，宗教，尤其是福音派，带有了不同的含义和内涵。两年前，一项民意调查显示，在自认为是福音派的人中，40% 的人不相信耶稣的神性。我不是神学家，但我很确定这是大多数福音派人士最能达成共识的一点，这表明这个词具有了不同的社会政治含义，有些人不想被贴上这个标签或与之产生关联。那么那些对宗教信仰“挑挑拣拣”的人呢？
I mean, I've known people who have, for example, stayed in the Roman Catholic faith, even though it's anti-LGBT, because they believe in other things. Is that common as well? Yeah, so anytime our beliefs and what we're being taught don't match up. we experience cognitive dissonance, this uncomfortable feeling. And so some people are able to assimilate those things together and are able to stay. So some people can say, well, you know, I want to partake in this part of religion or I believe in the community. And they disregard or kind of downplay or rationalize why they're staying.
我的意思是，我认识一些人，例如，尽管天主教反 LGBTQ，但他们仍然留在罗马天主教信仰中，因为他们相信其他东西。这种情况也很普遍吗？是的，每当我们的信仰与我们被教导的内容不匹配时，我们就会经历“认知失调”，即那种不舒服的感觉。有些人能够将这些东西融合在一起并留下来。所以有些人会说，好吧，你知道，我想参与宗教的这一部分，或者我相信这个社区。他们会忽视、淡化或合理化自己留下的原因。
But for other people, that discrepancy or that dissonance is so great, they can't reconcile those. And for them, that means a departure. That means either no longer identifying or leaving the religious community or having a major revision in their theological beliefs. In the U.S. is this mainly a Christian phenomenon or people leaving Islam, Judaism, Hinduism, other religions? We are seeing a decline across all religions, but in the U.S., it's particularly strong in Christianity, and that's likely because Christianity has been the majority religion in the U.S. So they're all going down, but Christianity is experiencing this more than other religions. And to most people who leave religion,
但对另一些人来说，这种差异或失调太大了，他们无法调和。对他们来说，这意味着离开。这意味着不再认同或离开宗教社区，或者在神学信仰上进行重大修正。在美国，这主要是基督教现象，还是人们也在离开伊斯兰教、犹太教、印度教和其他宗教？我们看到所有宗教都在衰落，但在美国，基督教的衰落尤为明显，这很可能是因为基督教一直是美国的多数派宗教。所以它们都在下降，但基督教比其他宗教经历得更严重。对于大多数离开宗教的人来说，
intent to come from more traditional conservative religious sects? You know, this is some research that we're currently exploring right now. We're currently examining the kind of religious history that one is raised in and whether or not that predicts if they stay or if they go and the consequences once they do. But we do think that when people are reporting to us, a lot of people have left moderately religious pasts. So we're thinking this is across the range. And is this a worldwide trend, or is it only happening in the U.S. and maybe other westernized nations? Yeah, so it is happening in the U.S. and other westernized nations, because in other parts of the world, religion is actually growing. There are parts of Africa and Asia where religion is on
他们是否倾向于来自更传统的保守宗教派别？你知道，这是我们目前正在探索的一些研究。我们正在研究一个人成长的宗教背景，以及这是否能预测他们是留下还是离开，以及离开后的后果。但我们确实认为，当人们向我们报告时，很多人都有过中度宗教化的过去。所以我们认为这涵盖了各个范围。这是一个全球性的趋势，还是只发生在美国和其他西方国家？是的，它确实发生在美国和其他西方国家，因为在世界其他地区，宗教实际上是在增长的。在非洲和亚洲的部分地区，宗教正在
the increase. And so we certainly need more cross-cultural research to quite understand what exactly is going on, what's motivating some folks to leave and other folks who reinvest more heavily in their religious beliefs. So what are the biggest challenges that face people when they leave their religion? Are those challenges mostly spiritual or are they secular or some combination? I think one of the biggest challenges is that when people leave religion, religion tends to linger with them. So my colleagues and I call this religious residue. So in our research, and this is cross-cultural research, we found that after people leave, they still think and feel and act in ways that are decidedly religious.
增加。因此，我们当然需要更多的跨文化研究来准确理解到底发生了什么，是什么在激励一些人离开，而另一些人则更投入地重新投资于他们的宗教信仰。那么，人们在离开宗教时面临的最大挑战是什么？这些挑战主要是精神上的，还是世俗的，或者是两者的结合？我认为最大的挑战之一是，当人们离开宗教时，宗教往往会挥之不去。我和同事称之为“宗教残留”。在我们的研究中，这是跨文化研究，我们发现人们离开后，他们的思考、感受和行为方式仍然带有明显的宗教色彩。
They still have aspects of their religious past that persist. So we like to think that religion is sticky. And so what this means is it might be more challenging for them to completely walk away from religion because it's so deeply ingrained in the way they think, in the way that they act and in habits that they've adopted, and because they're oftentimes surrounded by religious friends or religious family members. And so these social communities makes it hard to walk away. But besides this religious residue, which makes it hard to walk away, I think that religious
他们仍然保留着过去宗教生活的某些方面。所以我们喜欢说宗教是“粘性”的。这意味着他们可能更难完全摆脱宗教，因为它已经深深植根于他们的思维方式、行为方式以及他们养成的习惯中，而且他们往往被宗教朋友或宗教家庭成员所包围。因此，这些社交圈使得离开变得困难。但除了这种让离开变得困难的“宗教残留”之外，我认为宗教
dunes, as we might call them, the formerly religious, face a number of challenges. So one is, after leaving religion, life just feels a little bit less meaningful. Now, that doesn't mean that the only way to have meaning in life is through religion. And plenty of non-religious people have very meaningful lives. But religion offers this special kind of meaning. And when people leave, their meaning does go down a bit. We also see that they have a bit of a challenge oftentimes navigating relationships, especially with people who are still religious and expect them to still be religious
“完成者”（dunes），也就是曾经有宗教信仰的人，面临着许多挑战。首先，离开宗教后，生活感觉稍微没那么有意义了。现在，这并不意味着获得人生意义的唯一途径是通过宗教。许多非宗教人士也有非常有意义的生活。但宗教提供了一种特殊的意义。当人们离开时，他们的意义感确实会下降一点。我们还发现，他们在处理人际关系时往往会遇到一些挑战，特别是与那些仍然有宗教信仰、并期望他们也保持宗教信仰的人相处时，
and don't fully appreciate the change that they've experienced. And then finally, the last place where we see a little bit of challenge is crafting a new identity. So for many people for whom religion has been a central part of how they see themselves, finding a new way to conceptualize who they are, develop a strong self-conceptive, apart from religion, often offers a formidable challenge. In your book, you use three terms to describe what's happening to people who are becoming dissatisfied with their religion. You talk about religious deconstruction, religious
他们并不完全理解这些人所经历的变化。最后，我们看到的另一个挑战是构建新的身份。对于许多将宗教视为自我认知核心部分的人来说，找到一种新的方式来概念化自己，在宗教之外发展出强大的自我概念，往往是一个巨大的挑战。在您的书中，您用了三个术语来描述那些对宗教感到不满的人身上发生的事情。您谈到了“宗教解构”、“宗教
de-identification, and religious reconstruction. What does each of those terms mean? So religious deconstruction is the process when people start questioning their beliefs, They're struggling. They may experience some doubt. It's basically a time in which the religion is not really a source of strength or comfort for them, but they're really thinking deeply and wrestling with their religious beliefs. Now, they could land in two different places. So for some people, when they've broken down, they've questioned, they've started to revise their beliefs. Some of them revise and they land squarely still in religion. So they've reconstructed their religious beliefs, but they're still religious. Maybe they've experienced religious growth, or they've picked a different
去认同”和“宗教重建”。这些术语分别是什么意思？“宗教解构”是人们开始质疑自己信仰的过程，他们正在挣扎。他们可能会经历一些怀疑。这基本上是一个宗教不再真正成为他们力量或安慰来源的时期，但他们正在深入思考并与自己的宗教信仰进行博弈。现在，他们可能会有两种不同的结局。对于一些人来说，当他们打破、质疑并开始修正自己的信仰后，他们会进行修正，但仍然坚定地留在宗教中。所以他们重建了自己的宗教信仰，但他们仍然是有宗教信仰的。也许他们经历了宗教成长，或者他们选择了不同的
religious tradition to identify with, or they've evolved some of their beliefs, but they'd still say that they're religious. That's religious reconstruction. But for other folks, when the deconstruction and revision process lands them outside of religion, they've decided that the ways that they've grown and changed no longer fit within traditional organized religion, then they've likely de-identified. And by that is they no longer identify as religious, and they're finding new ways to organize how they think and how they feel outside of traditional religious structures. You know, religion, as I understand it, grew up as an explanation for a lot of the mysterious things that happen in the world. And I'm wondering, as we have become more scientific and begun to understand more things about the way the world was formed and where we all come from, I have advances in science had some. on people's becoming less religious.
宗教传统来认同，或者他们进化了一些信仰，但他们仍然会说自己是有宗教信仰的。这就是“宗教重建”。但对于另一些人来说，当解构和修正过程使他们置身于宗教之外时，他们认为自己的成长和变化不再适合传统的有组织宗教，那么他们很可能已经“去认同”了。也就是说，他们不再认同自己是有宗教信仰的，并且正在寻找新的方式来组织他们在传统宗教结构之外的思考和感受。你知道，据我理解，宗教的兴起是为了解释世界上发生的许多神秘事物。我想知道，随着我们变得更加科学，开始了解更多关于世界形成方式以及我们从哪里来的知识，科学的进步是否对人们变得不那么宗教化产生了一些影响？
Absolutely. And some of the reasons that people gave us, you know, that we put into this cultural stagnation bucket were exactly what you said. I used to believe in God, but then I learned about science, right? So throughout time, as you're mentioning, people would rely on God or the gods to meet needs that were outside of their control. So if they needed crops, they needed food, they needed rain, there were religious rituals or prayers or sacrifices that people could do in order to help.
绝对有。人们给我们的原因中，有一些我们归入“文化停滞”类别的，正是你所说的。我曾经相信上帝，但后来我了解了科学，对吧？所以纵观历史，正如你提到的，人们会依赖上帝或神灵来满足他们无法控制的需求。如果他们需要庄稼、食物、雨水，人们可以通过宗教仪式、祈祷或祭祀来寻求帮助。
to meet those needs. But as we've progressed and culture has filled in some of those gaps, you know, we don't necessarily rely on religious rituals in the same way. So if I'm worried about food, I might not do a religious ritual to try to evoke rain for my crops. I'll just drive to the grocery store. Or if I'm worried about being healed, I'm probably more likely to spend time researching what a good doctor would be and how to find adequate medical care and pay for my medical care, as opposed to, you know, begging for supernatural intervention. So I do think that as culture has progressed and as science has taken more of a forefront in our culture and society, it's possible that in those ways, reliance on God or gods or the supernatural agents has indeed
来满足这些需求。但随着我们的进步，文化填补了其中的一些空白，我们不一定以同样的方式依赖宗教仪式。所以如果我担心食物，我可能不会通过宗教仪式来祈求庄稼降雨。我会直接开车去杂货店。或者如果我担心被治愈，我可能更倾向于花时间研究什么样的医生好，如何找到合适的医疗护理并支付医疗费用，而不是祈求超自然的干预。所以我确实认为，随着文化的进步，随着科学在我们的文化和社会中占据更重要的地位，在这些方面，对上帝、神灵或超自然力量的依赖确实
decreased. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill for burner gas grill on special for only $199 and entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed
减少了。您的夏天从现在开始，Home Depot 阵亡将士纪念日促销活动现已开启。是时候用 Nextgrill 四炉燃气烤架开启夏季烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元；用 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅套装招待亲友，整个季节仅需 499 美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在 Home Depot 享受低价保证。
at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See homedepot.com slash price match for details. Is some of this the fault of religion, though, for not changing with these changes in our understanding of the world? I do think that
售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，适用除外条款。详情请参阅 homedepot.com/pricematch。不过，这是否是宗教的错，因为它没有随着我们对世界理解的变化而改变？我确实认为
religious people and religious, people in religious institutions who are comprised of people do need to pause and ask themselves in what ways are we stagnating and failing to meet the evolving needs of people around us, right? In what ways are we thinking that certain beliefs, certain practices, certain actions are incredibly timeless, and in what ways do we need to update? So when I talk about this with scholars, I talk about this with church leaders who are curious, what can we do to keep people in our pews. And sometimes they have trouble realizing that much of what they do that they think is timeless is actually culturally bound. They say, well, you know, we can't change anything. And they're
宗教人士和宗教机构中的人确实需要停下来问问自己，我们在哪些方面停滞不前，未能满足周围人不断变化的需求？我们在哪些方面认为某些信仰、某些做法、某些行为是永恒不变的，而在哪些方面我们需要更新？所以当我和学者们谈论这个问题时，我和那些好奇的教会领袖谈论这个问题，问我们能做些什么来留住信徒。有时他们很难意识到，他们认为永恒的许多事情实际上是受文化限制的。他们说，好吧，你知道，我们不能改变任何事情。而他们
telling me this as their church is in a strip mall, right? And they've got a coffee shop in the front. And they're projecting their music on a, you know, computer screen. All of these things were not around, you know, a hundred years ago. But somehow we think that they're part and parcel of what it means to be a core religious person. And so this fear of change and parsing out what's core to a religious belief and group versus what are things that we actually need to change and advance and evolve so we can meet these demands. I do think that there's an onus of responsibility that goes to the religious individuals and institutions to keep up with meeting some of these needs, to evolve alongside the people and our culture. You mentioned earlier that by the age of 30 that a certain
在告诉我这些话时，他们的教会就在一个购物中心里，对吧？他们的前台有一家咖啡店。他们把音乐投射在电脑屏幕上。所有这些东西在一百年前都是不存在的。但不知何故，我们认为它们是成为核心宗教人士的一部分。因此，这种对改变的恐惧，以及区分什么是宗教信仰和团体的核心，什么是我们实际上需要改变、推进和进化以满足这些需求的东西，我确实认为宗教个人和机构有责任跟上这些需求，与我们的人民和文化一起进化。您之前提到，到 30 岁时，有一定
percentage of people are likely to leave religion. Is there an age where it suddenly hits you that you're done with your religion? You know, I do think that it's a bit of a process. So for some people, it could be a slow process. I had a friend of mine who said, you know, I grew up religious and I was firmly at the religious table and then I kept sliding further and further and further down. And one day I realized, I just wasn't sitting at the table anymore. And I realized, oh, it just wasn't for me. Other people have more dramatic exits. They really wrestle with it. They just can't make sense of it or tragedy happens and they just can't square a version of a good, loving, supernatural being and their experiences and they leave more abruptly.
比例的人很可能会离开宗教。有没有一个年龄段会让你突然意识到你已经受够了你的宗教？你知道，我确实认为这是一个过程。对一些人来说，这可能是一个缓慢的过程。我的一位朋友说，我从小就有宗教信仰，我坚定地坐在宗教的餐桌旁，然后我不断地向下滑，向下滑。有一天我意识到，我只是不再坐在那张桌子旁了。我意识到，哦，它只是不适合我。其他人则有更戏剧性的退出。他们真的为此挣扎。他们只是无法理解它，或者悲剧发生了，他们无法调和善良、慈爱的超自然存在与他们的经历，于是他们更突然地离开了。
But I do think that there are probably times that are more likely to see religious change. So maybe when people leave home and go away to college, get exposed to new and different individuals, new and different ideas, that could be a first time when they start thinking and rethinking their religious beliefs. And then interestingly, as people have kids, especially if they've previously left religion, they might start reconsidering whether or not what role religion should play in the life of their children. So for some, if they relied on religion to learn and teach morals, and now they're no longer religious, if they want to teach their children some morals, they're going to need to figure out,
但我确实认为，可能存在一些更容易看到宗教变化的时期。比如当人们离开家去上大学，接触到新的不同的人、新的不同的想法时，这可能是他们开始思考和重新思考宗教信仰的第一次机会。然后有趣的是，当人们有了孩子，特别是如果他们之前已经离开宗教，他们可能会开始重新考虑宗教应该在他们孩子的生活中扮演什么角色。所以对于一些人来说，如果他们依赖宗教来学习和教授道德，而现在他们不再有宗教信仰，如果他们想教孩子一些道德，他们就需要弄清楚，
do we go back to church? But how do we go back to a religious community and keep the good, but keep out the bad? or are we going to do this differently? And so I think there are probably pressure points where religious change is more likely and it's around life and developmental transitions. But, I mean, religion isn't necessary for a person to be moral, right?
我们是回到教会吗？但我们如何回到一个宗教社区并保留好的部分，剔除坏的部分？还是我们要换一种方式？所以我认为可能存在一些压力点，宗教变化更有可能发生，这通常围绕着生活和发展的转变。但是，宗教并不是一个人有道德的必要条件，对吧？
I mean, there's no research that says if you leave religion that you somehow become less moral than you were before. Absolutely not. It's not required at all. But for those people who were raised religious and we see some research that suggests that many people hold a perception that people who don't believe in God aren't trustworthy, that they're somehow less moral, even though, as you're mentioning, all the research suggests
我的意思是，没有任何研究表明如果你离开宗教，你就会变得比以前道德水平低。绝对不是。这根本不是必需的。但对于那些在宗教环境中长大的人来说，我们看到一些研究表明，许多人认为不相信上帝的人是不值得信任的，他们以某种方式道德水平较低，尽管正如你提到的，所有的研究都表明
it's not necessarily true. There's much more research that suggests religious people say that they're more moral. But when the rubber meets the road, we're about the same. Religious, non-religious people, act about the same. So for those who are raised religious and were taught, part of why you have to be religious is to be moral, it creates another layer of deciding, do we believe that that's true? And how do we go about teaching and passing on being an ethical, good, civil person in a way that perhaps we weren't taught? We haven't developed the skills yet to do. You're talking the book about how some beliefs are harder than others to shake, especially negative beliefs, like the belief in hell or the devil. Why is that?
这不一定是真的。有更多的研究表明，宗教人士声称自己更有道德。但当真正付诸实践时，我们其实差不多。宗教人士和非宗教人士的行为方式大致相同。所以对于那些在宗教环境中长大并被教导“你必须有宗教信仰才能有道德”的人来说，这增加了另一层决定：我们相信这是真的吗？我们该如何教导和传递成为一个有道德、善良、文明的人，而这种方式可能不是我们被教导的那样？我们还没有掌握这样做的技能。您在书中谈到有些信仰比其他信仰更难动摇，尤其是负面信仰，比如对地狱或魔鬼的信仰。为什么会这样？
Yeah, so this all came about. My wife is a clinician, so a mental health therapist. and she sees people undergoing religious change. And she said, you know, among the people who have left religion, they still can't shake this fear of hell and the devil. Because they're so worried, she mentioned, that they could be wrong. Like, the stakes are so high, right? So a number of them fear, like, well, if I stop believing in hell and the devil and I'm wrong, that's, you know, I'm going to be realizing my mistake for all of eternity.
是的，这一切都是这样产生的。我的妻子是一名临床医生，也就是心理健康治疗师。她看到人们正在经历宗教变化。她说，在那些离开宗教的人中，他们仍然无法摆脱对地狱和魔鬼的恐惧。因为他们非常担心，她提到，他们可能是错的。因为赌注太高了，对吧？所以他们中的一些人担心，如果我不再相信地狱和魔鬼，而我错了，那我就要在永恒中意识到我的错误。
So they might think. And so, you know, she suggested, why don't, why don't I study this? So I came to my students. I said, let's study this. And sure enough, we found that after people left religion, they still believe in hell and the devil significantly more than people have never been religious. And so we think there's a couple reasons. So one reason why is that just in general, psychologically speaking, negative information carries more weight than positive information. We just have what's called a negativity bias,
他们可能会这样想。所以，她建议，我为什么不研究一下这个呢？所以我找到我的学生。我说，让我们研究一下这个。果然，我们发现人们离开宗教后，他们对地狱和魔鬼的信仰仍然显著高于那些从未有过宗教信仰的人。所以我们认为有几个原因。一个原因是，从心理学上讲，负面信息比正面信息更有分量。我们只是有一种所谓的“负面偏见”，
where there's more keyed in on that. A second reason is because of the existential ramifications. So it's a bit like Pascal's wager. So Pascal's wager was like, well, God may or may not exist, but it's better to believe and be wrong than not believe and be wrong. And so we think because the existential stakes are so high, people might just hedge a little bit because they're a little bit concerned, you know, what if I'm wrong? But what about the converse? Do people hang on to a belief in heaven and a deity? Yeah.
我们更关注这一点。第二个原因是存在主义的后果。这有点像帕斯卡的赌注。帕斯卡的赌注是说，上帝可能存在也可能不存在，但相信了即使错了也比不相信而错了要好。所以我们认为，因为存在主义的赌注太高了，人们可能会稍微对冲一下，因为他们有点担心，万一我错了呢？但反过来呢？人们会坚持对天堂和神灵的信仰吗？是的。
So what's interesting about that one is it's almost like people are afraid to let go of the fear of hell and the devil. but even though they've let go of this belief in heaven and God, it's almost that they want that. There's a wishful, I wish heaven were still true. And so the converse of that is they've probably relinquished it, but there's more of a longing for goodness. I sure, life sure was easier when I held that belief. It made grief easier. It made the troubles in my life easier, thinking that this wasn't all that there is. And a lot of times there's a lament once people come to a belief in their mind that this is all there is because then they think, well, it took me how many years of my life to realize this? And now I've got a short amount left.
关于这一点有趣的是，人们似乎害怕放弃对地狱和魔鬼的恐惧，但即使他们放弃了对天堂和上帝的信仰，他们似乎又想要那个。有一种愿望，我希望天堂仍然是真的。所以反过来，他们可能已经放弃了它，但对善良有一种更强烈的渴望。我敢肯定，当我持有那种信仰时，生活肯定更容易。它让悲伤更容易。它让生活中的麻烦更容易，认为这并不是全部。很多时候，一旦人们在心中形成“这就是全部”的信念，就会有一种哀叹，因为他们会想，我花了多少年才意识到这一点？而现在我剩下的时间不多了。
As people leave organized religion, where do they tend to put the energy that they had been putting there? As you're studying this, what do you find people telling you about how they rechannel their thinking and their essence? Yeah, so for a lot of people leaving religion doesn't mean no longer engaging or interacting with their spirituality. So we're seeing this rise of the spiritual but not religious. And so there are different places where people might live out that spirituality. So for some, it's in nature. So going on a hike or spending time in a beautiful area. For others, it's the cosmos or kind of being connected with the transcendent. So experiences of awe or feeling small. Other people, really invest in other humans and other people, right? So through volunteering or witnessing big communal actions of social justice or kind of doing the right thing is a sense of spirituality for many. And then for some, they find a deep sense of spirituality just by living a life of integrity and authenticity to who they are. So their sense of spirituality comes from within. Well, there's a lot of talk lately about the use of psychedelics in order to commune with the universe. I'm just wondering if you've looked at that at all and whether that has any influence on whether
当人们离开有组织宗教时，他们倾向于把之前投入在那里的精力放在哪里？当您研究这个问题时，您发现人们告诉您他们如何重新引导他们的思想和本质？是的，对许多人来说，离开宗教并不意味着不再参与或互动他们的灵性。所以我们看到了“精神但非宗教”的兴起。因此，人们可以在不同的地方实践这种灵性。对一些人来说，是在大自然中。比如去徒步旅行或在美丽的地方度过时光。对另一些人来说，是宇宙，或者与超越性的东西相连。比如敬畏的体验或感到自己的渺小。其他人则真正投资于其他人，对吧？所以通过志愿服务或见证社会正义的集体行动，或者做正确的事，对许多人来说是一种灵性。然后对一些人来说，他们仅仅通过过一种正直和真实的生活，忠于自己，就能找到一种深刻的灵性感。所以他们的灵性感来自内心。嗯，最近有很多关于使用迷幻药来与宇宙交流的讨论。我只是想知道您是否研究过这一点，以及当人们参与其中时，这是否对他们变得更宗教或更不宗教有任何影响？
people become more or less religious as they engage. Yeah, so my colleagues recently got a grant that we're currently working on looking at spiritual yearning. So where are people looking for spirituality outside of traditional religion, particularly among the duns and the never-been religious folks? And a lot of what they're telling us is they want what religion gave them. They want the supernatural experiences. They want that deep connection with the transcendent, but without religion.
是的，我的同事最近获得了一笔拨款，我们目前正在研究“精神渴望”。所以人们在传统宗教之外寻找灵性的地方在哪里，特别是在“无神论者”（duns）和从未有过宗教信仰的人群中？他们告诉我们的很多内容是，他们想要宗教给他们的东西。他们想要超自然的体验。他们想要与超越性的深刻联系，但没有宗教。
So everything religion gave them stripped of religion. And we do see that people who are spiritual but not religious are much more likely to think that psychedelics are a gateway for communication from the supernatural. And so we're probably more open to engaging in psychedelic experiences as a way of potentially replicating some of the supernatural aspects that religion offered without some of the baggage, so to speak, of their previous religious experiences. Now, I mentioned this noting that in many cultures where psychedelic use has been prominent, it has been a part of spiritual or religious or cultural traditions. And so we should be thoughtful and mindful of what it means to interact with
所以宗教给他们的一切，剥离了宗教。我们确实看到，精神但非宗教的人更有可能认为迷幻药是与超自然交流的门户。因此，他们可能更愿意参与迷幻体验，作为一种潜在地复制宗教提供的一些超自然方面的方式，而没有他们之前宗教经历的那些“包袱”。现在，我提到这一点时注意到，在许多迷幻药使用突出的文化中，它一直是精神、宗教或文化传统的一部分。因此，我们应该深思熟虑，并注意以尊重、尊重传统的方式与这些类型的社区互动，并了解迷幻药的使用在过去是如何与宗教、文化和精神传统联系在一起的。您在书中谈到了您自己在这一领域的旅程，从在一个宗教家庭长大到质疑宗教。这就是启发您做这项工作的动力吗？你知道，我想这一定是其中的一部分。有一句老话，研究就是研究。所以，是的，我的确在成长过程中经历了一些情况，一些触动心灵的时刻，这确实让我质疑我被教导的东西，这确实让我怀疑我一直以来所持有的许多假设，这些假设在生活中完全
these types of communities in a way that's respectful, that honors the traditions, and can understand how psychedelic use has been connected with religious, cultural, and spiritual traditions in the past. You talk in the book about your own journey in this area from growing up at a religious family to questioning religion. Is that what inspired you to do this work? You know, I think it, I think it has to be part. So there's the old adage that, you know, research is research. And so, yeah, I mean, I've experienced a few situations kind of growing up, just some, you know, just some touchstone moments that really caused me to question things that I was taught that really cast into to doubt a lot of the assumptions that I had been walking through life holding that were completely
未经检验。所以，是的，我自己的宗教挣扎，我自己的宗教质疑可能激励我开始做这项研究。我找到了一位愿意和我一起写拨款申请的同事。我们很感激有机会跨文化研究这个问题。所以当我最初开始做这项研究时，我很惊讶。我们没想到会有这么多人认同自己是宗教“无神论者”。我们做得越多，就越意识到，天哪，我想我们发现了什么。人数比我们想象的要多得多。我们很感激能站在做这项工作的前沿。现在，您在一所基督教学院工作。这对您来说是个问题吗？
unchecked. And so, yeah, part of my own religious struggles, my own religious questioning probably motivated me to start doing this research. And I found a colleague who was willing to write a grant together with me. And we were grateful to get an opportunity to study this cross-culturally. And so I've been surprised when we initially started doing this research. We didn't think that we were going to get very many people who identified as religious duns. And the more we did this, the more we realized, oh my goodness, I think we're onto something. There's a lot more people than we thought. And we're grateful to be on the frontier of doing some of this work. Now, you work at a Christian college. Is that an issue for you?
是的。所以，你知道，没错，我在一所基督教学院工作，我的宗教信仰已经发生了相当大的变化。我很感激能在一个真正鼓励自由探究、表达自由的地方工作，它确实鼓励我们，它的教职员工，去深入研究正在发生的现象，并鼓励我们探索这些事情。您研究的另一个领域是“智力谦逊”和谦逊的美德。您能告诉我一点关于那项工作的内容，以及它与您关于宗教的工作有什么关系吗？是的，我确实认为它们是相连的。所以我在智力谦逊方面的一些工作，即承认我们并不了解一切，
Yeah. So, you know, right, I work at a Christian college and my religious beliefs have changed considerably. And I'm grateful to be at a place that really does encourage free inquiry, freedom of expression. it really encourages us, its faculty, to really study deeply phenomenon that are going on, and it encourages us to explore those things. Another area that you study is intellectual humility and the virtue of being humble. Can you tell me a little bit about that work and how does it relate to your work on religion? Yeah, I do see them as connected. So some of my work on intellectual humility, so admitting that we don't know everything,
承认我们可能会犯错，你知道，我喜欢说我们所有人对每件事都部分错误，并且肯定在某些事情上是错误的。我确实认为它们是相连的，因为我确实认为，如果一个人对自己诚实并保持智力上的谦逊，他们就会承认他们并不确定一切，对吧？包括重大的存在主义问题。所以我们实际上获得了一笔拨款来研究智力谦逊是否能帮助人们处理生活中这些重大问题，这些重大的存在主义问题。我以为智力谦逊的人会做得更好。但我完全错了。这是一个智力上令人谦卑的经历。我的假设完全是倒过来的。我们发现
admitting that we could that we're likely wrong you know i'd like to say that all of us are partially wrong about everything and definitely wrong about some things um i do see them as connected because i do think that there's a degree to which if someone's being honest with themselves and intellectually humble with themselves they will admit that they don't know for certain everything right including big existential questions and so we had actually gotten a grant to study whether or not intellectual humility would help people deal with some of these big questions in life, these big existential questions. And I thought the more intellectually humble people would do better. And I was completely wrong. It was an intellectually humbling experience. My hypotheses were completely backwards. We found
智力谦逊的人表现得稍微差一点。我们所说的“差”，是指他们的幸福感没有那么高。这让他们感到更焦虑。他们更痛苦。我认为这在某种程度上是有道理的，因为当关于死后会发生什么以及人生的意义是什么的赌注如此之高时。而你说，好吧，我不确定，我可能是错的，对吧？或者我相信这个，但如果我遇到足够强有力的证据，我愿意修正。这可能会引起焦虑，这解释了为什么我们如此强烈地被这些确定、安全和确定的信仰方式和存在方式所吸引。所以在我看来，我确实认为两者是相连的。我认为许多经历过宗教变化的人已经表现出了足够的智力谦逊，可以说，我真的以为我永远不会改变主意的事情，
that intellectually humble people did a little worse. And by worse, we mean they didn't have as high well-being. It made them feel more anxious. They were more distressed. And I think part of that makes sense because when the stakes are so high about what happens after you die and what's the meaning of life. And you say, well, I'm not quite sure I could be wrong, right? Or I'm believing this, but I'm open to revise if I've encountered sufficiently strong evidence. That can be anxiety provoking, which suggests why we're so strongly drawn to these sure and secure and certain ways of believing and ways of being. And so in my mind, I do see the two as being connected. Many people, I think, who have undergone religious change have demonstrated intellectual humility enough to say something I really thought I would never change my mind on.
我实际上正在改变主意，因为我发现了建议我应该改变的证据。我认为采取这种谦逊的态度是非常令人钦佩和明智的。所以在我看来，是的，它们是相连的。在实践层面上，对于那些可能正在与他们从小接受的宗教作斗争，并觉得它不再适合他们的听众，您有什么建议？他们应该问自己什么样的问题，他们应该寻求什么样的支持？所以对于正在经历这些的人，我想说的第一件事是，你并不孤单。对。
I'm actually changing my mind on because I've found evidence that suggests that I should. And I think that there's something admirable and there's something very kind of wise about taking that posture of humility. And so in my mind, yeah, they are connected. On a practical level, what kind of advice do you have for listeners who may be struggling? with the religion that they were raised in and feel that it no longer fits them. And what kind of questions should they be asking themselves and what kind of support should they seek? So for people who are going through this, the first thing I want to say is you're not alone. Right.
所以这是让我印象深刻的第一件事，很多人也在经历这种情况。我会鼓励人们朝着一个方向努力，让他们的信仰体系成为他们价值观和经历的真实反映。因此，当他们检查自己的信仰清单时，考虑一下，他们想保留哪些方面，他们想丢弃哪些东西？对许多人来说，这是一个极其具有挑战性的过程。因此，对于许多人，特别是那些经历过宗教和精神虐待与创伤的人来说，找到一位在宗教和精神虐待与创伤方面有经验的好治疗师是非常有价值的。我还认为，当他们经历这个过程时，要意识到处理一些社会关系将是具有挑战性的，特别是如果一个人的家庭是有宗教信仰的，并期望你有宗教信仰而你却没有，这会产生很大的压力，很大的紧张感。
So that was the first thing that struck me was a lot of people are experiencing this as well. I would encourage people to move toward a place where their set of beliefs is an authentic reflection of their values and their experiences. So as they move through examining the inventory of their beliefs, consider, you know, what aspects do they want to retain, which are things that they want to discard? And for many people, this is a deeply challenging process. And so for many, especially for those who have experienced religious and spiritual abuse and trauma, finding a good therapist who has experience with, you know, religious and spiritual abuse and trauma can be incredibly valuable. I also think that as they're moving through this, realizing that it's going to be challenging to navigate some social relationships, especially if one's family is religious and expects you to be religious and you're not, that creates a lot of stress, a lot of tension,
所以这是让我印象最深的第一件事，那就是很多人也正在经历同样的情况。我鼓励人们朝着一个方向努力，让他们的信仰体系能够真实地反映他们的价值观和经历。因此，当他们审视自己的信仰清单时，可以思考一下，哪些方面是他们想要保留的，哪些是他们想要摒弃的？对许多人来说，这是一个极具挑战性的过程。因此，对于许多人，特别是那些经历过宗教和精神虐待及创伤的人来说，找到一位在宗教和精神虐待及创伤方面有经验的优秀治疗师会非常有价值。我也认为，当他们经历这个过程时，要意识到处理某些社会关系将会充满挑战，特别是如果一个人的家庭是信教的，并期望你也信教，而你却不信，这会产生很大的压力和紧张感。
and that needs to be navigated carefully. And then the last piece of advice I would encourage folks to move toward is an identity that is not based solely on what someone isn't, right? So an identity that goes beyond not being religious or being, you know, I used to be religious. And that's more of a deficit identity. But moving towards a presence identity of, well, what are you? You're more than just that. In what ways can you live out those values?
这需要谨慎对待。我鼓励大家追求的最后一个建议是，建立一种不仅仅基于“非某某”的身份认同。也就是说，这种身份认同不应仅仅局限于“我不信教”或“我曾经信教”。这更像是一种缺失型的身份认同。我们应该转向一种存在型的身份认同，即：你到底是谁？你不仅仅是这些。你可以通过哪些方式去践行你的价值观？
Many people have said, you know, this has been a challenging transition. I never thought that I'd do it. And the world is so much full of wonder and awe and curiosity on the other side of it, that flourishing is possible after leaving religion. And that's my hope in writing this book and conducting this research is to help point people toward resources and ways in which they can flourish with or without religion. Have you found that most people walk away? Do they tend to become just agnostic or do they become outright atheists? You know, that's a wide range. Some people will, you know, some people will say, I'm absolutely certain there is no God. Other people will hold more of a stance of, well, there might be, there might not be, I'm not really sure.
许多人说，这是一个充满挑战的转变。我从未想过自己会这样做。但在跨越这一步之后，你会发现世界充满了惊奇、敬畏和好奇，离开宗教后依然可以蓬勃发展。我写这本书并进行这项研究，就是希望能帮助人们找到资源和途径，无论是否有宗教信仰，都能过得充实。你发现大多数人离开后会怎样？他们是变得不可知论，还是彻底成为无神论者？这其实范围很广。有些人会说，我绝对确定没有上帝。而另一些人则持更中立的态度，认为也许有，也许没有，我不太确定。
and other people land more firmly in a, I still feel spiritual and I still want to have spiritual connection, but it's certainly not in the way that I was taught. And it's certainly not through this narrow organized religion. And finally, what are the big questions you're looking at now? What do you still want to know? And where's your next grad going? Yeah, so we still want to know where are people finding meaning and engaging with existential questions outside of organized religion? How are they meeting their spiritual needs. And what types of religions are resilient to kind of religious change and which ones are more likely to have people be unable to withstand some of these questions and more likely to cause people to leave, right? Are there certain ones that are
还有些人则更坚定地认为，我仍然感到精神上的需求，我仍然希望有精神上的联系，但这肯定不是我过去被教导的那种方式，也肯定不是通过这种狭隘的组织化宗教来实现的。最后，你现在关注的重大问题是什么？你还想了解什么？你接下来的研究方向是什么？是的，我们仍然想知道，人们在组织化宗教之外，从哪里寻找意义并探讨存在主义问题？他们是如何满足自己的精神需求的？哪些类型的宗教对宗教变革具有韧性？哪些宗教更容易让人无法承受这些质疑，从而导致人们离开？有没有某些宗教是
better suited or less well suited for times of suffering and adversity when it leads to religious change? Well, Dr. Grand Togran, I want to thank you for joining me today. It's been very interesting. Thank you so much for having me. This has been great. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at 8PA.org.
在面对苦难和逆境导致宗教信仰发生改变时，表现得更好或更差？好的，Grand Togran博士，非常感谢您今天能参加我们的节目。这非常有意思。非常感谢您的邀请。这次交流很棒。您可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org，或者在Apple、Spotify、YouTube以及任何您收听播客的平台上找到《心理学谈话》往期节目。如果您喜欢我们的内容，请订阅并留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。
Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening. The American Psychological Association. Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《心理学谈话》由Lee Weinerman制作。感谢您的收听。美国心理学会。Mills。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。